Bravo tu m'as retrouvé.
C'est ça que tu cherches ?
Me touche pas connard !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Lâche-la tout de suite !
Allons, tu vas pas tirer sur ta charmante amie ?
L'écoute pas, bute-le faut pas qu'il s'échappe !
Non.
Je ne peux pas.
Mon insigne de police !
C'est bon, je crois que ma bonne...
La sainte bible !
Si c'est pas la preuve qu'il existe ça !
Evite celle-là !
Ma dent en or !
Et moi qui mangeait trop de bonbons !
Incroyable !
J'ai vraiment cru que c'était la fin !
C'est vraiment trop trop tôt.
Augustin ?
Ah bah enfin !
Allez, ça dégage.
Je reviens pour toi après car il faut que je recharge ce putain de flingue ! Merde ! Une journée de gachée ! c'est pas gratuit ! Putain !
C'est bon je crois que....
Je crois maintenant que...
Il existe !
Il ex...
Moi qui mangeait trop de bonbon !
Ça ç'est...